welcome to boot camp Shaolin style
straighten the body
this is Lu Zhang Zhang one of shaolin's
youngest novice monks Zhang Zhang lived
with his parents in Fujian province
until he was selected for a place at the
temple that was a year ago since then
he's lived at Shaolin Temple with more
than 40 other novice monks all of them
hand-picked from kung fu schools all
over China training 3 hours in the
morning two and a half hours in the
afternoon
365 days a year
always under the watchful eye of yin xiu
shaolin's drill sergeant
what if it's right his job to turn this
bunch of kids into real kung-fu monks
keep your back straight pick properly
the Chinese words kung fu' evoke honor
and glory but they translate into
English simply as hard work it's a
punishing regime even for these boys the
best of the best
that's why Shaolin calls its novices the
hopefuls back home each of these boys
was a star but now they're all competing
with each other each hoping he'll be one
of the few who'll eventually get what
they've come here for a place on the
a-team
xiaolin performance teams travel the
world captivating audiences with
dazzling kung-fu displays
[Music]
it's a ticket out of rural China to a
life of stardom